[Music]
this is the grave of silas reed
silas died at the age of 11 weeks his
cause of death is listed as lung fever
now along with not being a professional
genealogist i'm not a professional
historian so feel free to correct me if
i'm wrong on anything i'm about to say
or really anything i say ever
so in the 19th century and before
fever was considered the sickness itself
rather than a symptom or a manifestation
of an illness
this is also why for causes of death a
lot of times the cause of death is
listed as a symptom so what we would
know now as a symptom they didn't really
have the diagnostic tools that we have
now or the medicines so really they just
focused on what was going on with the
person just before they died so because
of that the word fever found its way
into a lot of disease names in these
causes of death so from my research lung
fever is most likely pneumonia
pneumonia was a pretty common disease a
pretty common killer
in the 19th century and long before
nowadays we have a lot more treatment
for
pneumonia both viral and bacterial
but back then it was a pretty scary
thing for parents of young kids
silas had an older brother named freddy
freddy died almost exactly a year after
silas he was eight years old and he died
of typhoid fever another very common
cause of death
from times before there were antiseptics
and general knowledge of germ theory
these are some of my favorite grapes to
clean the grapes that
are pretty much unreadable it feels
really good to
give this person their name back
and know
that someone is mentioning their name
even 150 some odd years after they have
died
silas and his brother are both buried
under this really beautiful tree that
easily could have been there when they
were buried but it's not something that
i'm really qualified to say
one thing about graves under trees is
that they tend to degrade a lot faster
because there's a lot more moisture
which promotes moss growth
so silas and freddy's grapes will
probably become grown over more quickly
than if they were out in the open
and here it is post rinsing
[Music]
i've been really interested in history
genealogy cemeteries as long as i can
remember it's been a lifelong
fascination there's a website called
find a grave which is basically what it
sounds like
if you
know you have an ancestor that's buried
in a particular cemetery in another
country or another state you can request
a photo of your ancestors grave and that
request goes out to anybody who's
identified themselves as a volunteer
within a certain
radius of where the cemetery is where
the person's buried so a woman in iowa
has lineage that traces back to vermont
and she knew she had seen
her
i think it's her great great maybe great
grandmother's grave um in a cemetery
near me
and
didn't have a picture of it so she
requested it through find a grave when i
found the grave it was in pretty rough
shape it was covered in lichen and it
was pretty much unreadable so when the
woman saw my picture
she
asked if i would be willing to
clean it for her so that it was more
readable so after that i kind of
assembled my tools
got everything together
and i cleaned that stone
but basically it was just something that
i found super therapeutic and
really rewarding
so it's the thing i've continued
[Music]